hello reject nation I'm Greg Allen and
I'm Joan snow we're going to do a
reaction review today for episode 5 of
Game of Thrones reaction out in the
living room review back in here but
before we do that John there is
something I got to tell you I am feeling
particularly unstoppable today thanks to
this snazzy new watch from my fourth
dope
Vince arrow collective big thank you to
them for saying these nifty watches over
these boys are makers of sharp luxury
watches so the distinct looked in really
a good quality feel check this out I
genuinely like these watches I'm so glad
we get to do a shout out for these guys
especially for John and I who we are
frequently seen you're wearing stuff
around our risk and whether you're
dressing up is your favorite movie
gentleman or just dressing to impress
Vince arrows goal is to make the modern
gentleman look and feel unstoppable and
as we all learn from films about modern
gentlemen a watch is a pretty important
accoutrement that's right I know some
big words and you'll never be free of
the crippling passage of time and these
watches they're stainless steel I wish
you could feel this the ones we haven't
particularly to have marble in them very
fancy and all the watches have scratch
resistant sapphire coated glass we've
got luminous hands they're water
resistant if you're looking for a nicer
kind of watch that's not going to cost
you like a year's allowance or does a
great gift for somebody spectrum you can
use our discount link in the description
box below zero collective my friend Erin
said all right let's go watch Game of
Thrones the most Italian show you'll
ever see
alright guys so we're going to watch
episode 5 of Game of Thrones right now
we would recorded this on a regular
camera but that cuts every 12 minutes or
recording this from the webcam right now
we're watching this one on the TV
there's only gonna be highlights by the
way I'm going to show you a whole hour
long let's just paying attention to a
lot of dialogue oh yeah oh yeah
[Music]
what save his life you saw the dragon
[Laughter]
news Mel's Delilah thank you I hope you
ensure there's me and Joey together we
will be the world a better place to be
found it all over team and stuff Oh
dudes here is not like we're together
I like this you gotta blow trouble we
are again this war is already white one
great house in the world
damn it honey Oh Tyrion man hello
damn your grace
mrs. crust old notions romantic cbc dr.
Benton I don't here to put mention if
ever comes in action minute if you get
it isn't she oh you [ __ ] Gary sometimes
the literal dragon food
mad at petting of it my head my like
McNichols undermining its Arney really
fashionable that practical hear it
though watch John really interrupt it
he's not progress to the nail feel
something haha grace area competition
shop now on Santa's Jorah
I wouldn't hold our shaker know where I
am and becoming crazy look at the budget
on these bad 100 we're going to fight
some white Walker single artist said she
might have 100 is it hard - oh yeah this
backwards in that garden is drama North
Carolina Washington oh really Shawn in
the dead in zombie but it is Gotham self
himself he wasn't sure I find you oh
this guy's been rap for a log a thon
over my silly Willy he's changing at me
you need to be you need to understand
her way let's go tunnel okay - do you
think I'll sit with you not if you swim
dude go get ready guys do it
what No
we didn't find more to see how the first
my kitchen tool if you did that scar
Bishop some integers cottage we looking
through pool to the scholar the world
back there some arrangement arranged
with you live arranged to tell them he's
pregnant
what how do you talk I got four horn
allowing appears doesn't sir I will
subscribe you may not get here as he
issues an annulment swap Prince Rhaegar
and reimagine so now the same time in a
secret anything dawn is that's a common
thing
[Music]
leaving waving ensuring one stash
[Music]
so I'm good kill would say right there
haha oh he do got some mouth of the
woman staring
oh sweet
[Music]
I'll have it you're like a lie this is
apple pie God that's an Arab mr. lamarka
later full is off
[Music]
[Music]
it really is Brad's health right about
now
[Music]
oh is that it ah I'm not going to be
around next week yeah do this for money
I'm doing Colorado it's true that I'll
do it myself or if you'll step away
because I'm going to want to see that
hey don't watch my review we're gonna
shoot another one of these day I love
how three episodes in a row there's
battles and [ __ ] the first time you
study here yeah yeah I know dad there's
some pretty degree complain or some
pretty good stuff so my research neatly
yeah let's go back to the other room max
what's that
alright so let's talk about the scenes
that really stood out to us the scenes
who really feel we could comment on here
will go in order of the habit scenes one
the first part that really stood out to
me was when dick on and randyll Tarly
yeah she burned him up threw him alive
what stood out to me it's just how
conflicting this is all really becoming
for Tyrion man yeah they're in feel
terrible whenever these deaths occurred
he does whatever he can to prevent this
and whenever Daenerys decides to kill
that they won't follow her she gets like
feel that fire in her eyes you know like
I dragon blood inside of her 1 Tyrion
knows tyranny so well then you know like
you start to yeah you really start to
feel for him being like please don't
rule with an iron fist Celeste you know
especially if you want to be known for
being this Liberator and this new kind
of Queen you don't do [ __ ] like because
there was a scene earlier in this season
Masson day is talking about like people
choose to follow her not because they
have to follow her but because they want
to follow her and whenever she does a
conquest like that and she treats people
this way and then kills the ones who
won't bend to me in such a terrifying
manner these are people who are
following her because they feel they
have to not because they want to so it's
going against everything that even
people like John snow was starting to
have faith in her part of what I love
about the shows that you see it from
everybody's point of view and
everybody's you know struggles because
nobody had 100% of the context that
everybody else does you know that's a
really tough call and I you know like
you got a look at the soldiers is Pete
- you know they gotta want to fight on
your behalf you know it over the course
of Daenerys is art I like that it's
they've decided to flirt with these
things because we watched her make good
decisions and bad decisions across you
know across this whole thing and like
the whole point of hers that she's the
daughter of Rhaegar you know people fear
you know didn't mean the dog but
whenever she does something like this
it's like that's I hated that yeah and
especially when you're running on the
platform of I'm not my dad yeah and you
just said that to these people I think I
think in that scenes you know she's like
bothers to differentiate or so even
though you did it in a different way it
still makes me wonder yeah Alan where is
this going to go down the road the more
challenges you face exactly exactly and
the scene when Jon is petting hydro gong
oh yeah it's like right away you're like
ah that dragon smells the Targaryen and
dagga I mean there was that scene when
Tyrion tete the dragon in an earlier
season so it's not like these dragons
are untenable in that was cific moment
though you're like no Joe Rogan senses
something in this Jon Snow guy oh yeah
no yeah it was a Harry and buck beat
yeah I was like you know okay should
respect you know you valor be touched
know and you know you develop trust I
always loved moments like that it looks
so good when he was petting him it was
so amazing
yeah I wonder if that may have been a
combo of because they can make some
really impressive animatronics now
that'll move and especially for those
close-ups we're all you know I didn't
know yeah yeah that was loved those
kinds of respect scenes you know Jorah
returning I was like how do we got
watching the episode was you're
reuniting with Daenerys because you know
like when he left in the last season he
made a promise to her he said he was
fulfill innings sure enough he does and
he returns it's like guy sings better
than ever little less she know his whole
skin looks really disgusting and
stealing from all the flesh peeling off
okay I have flesh peeling and good
because I mean this season is making me
really happy for Jorah because that that
is that a long and difficult road
journey throughout this show and finally
he does and to finally see at least a
few
else with him see him get Thrones and
bone you know yeah cured of his horrific
dizzy and and you know to be finally it
seems like accepted you know as a part
of Daenerys at least as part of her
organization you know they got eyes for
each other oh dude I mean there were
this show this episode hinted that that
they had like pretty good like the first
time I thought they were gonna kiss and
when they were saying goodbye to her
having that moment there where it looked
like she was kind of into him a little
bit you know hey I mean he is proven
over snow like I'm his dedication
salutely he's done like you know curing
that advanced degree of greyscale seem
like a relative impossibility and still
Joris knocking down passed out
absolutely antarians conflict with him
feeling a responsibility for the violent
acts with Daenerys is committing actions
that she's taking you know because he's
like I'm not the head on the hand but I
like that conversation he has it varies
we're not seeing a lot of various lately
pointing out that you know I've been in
your position and you know I would lie
to myself to and tell myself I'm not
responsible but he's the hand he's the
helping hand and we're all responsible
if this is what goes in I like the
conflict this is putting Tyrion in
because I loved I like the story plot
choice of having Tyrion side with
Daenerys and teaming up with her but at
the end of the day he is a Lannister he
was always different from the rest of
the Lannisters and watching Lannister
armies being slaughtered this is still
like his family and he doesn't like
violence in Genesis seems like he's not
a fan of people being killed yeah one
end up taking life as though it doesn't
mean much you know and and yeah I mean
he is I loved the the amount of humanity
that had sort of entered that character
over the course of time and it does seem
like this whole business of Thrones and
kingdoms and stuff is a difficult one
the more experienced yes you know and
that yeah that moment where he watches
you know like his former bannermen just
get burnt to a crisp and he walks among
their ashes and yeah like cuz he's
fought alongside with them yeah and and
like I love that there they take the
time for those kinds of conflict because
that's these are all the things we're
really fighting for yeah like everyone's
concerned with who's cat
this and who thrown that and whose
vendetta needs to be serviced and
whatnot you know it's the people who
live in the kingdom he does a really
good job of showing the effects you know
Peter Dinklage like his performance
especially in this episode is really
good amazing when they're off the table
and cheering it comes up with a plan to
bring a white Walker back just that
whole episode made me go world smart but
it's same plantain same time well a
White Walkers Cersei should present him
a common enemy in a way when that one's
a bit of a curveball because I'm like
that is a I was not expecting this now
mine to pop up at all I can only wait to
see how they pay it off because that
does seem like a like a sharp left turn
it seems like a very tall order but I do
like that it is leaning to a different
configuration of these characters again
like when they set out on the mission
now we've got a new ensemble going out
to tackle this wasn't too sure how to
feel about that scene when REO was
confronting Sansa gets be kind of
worried about their relationship Arya is
like these are some killer inside that
girl there's a killer inside that girl
and she stands I feel like she would
side with Jon on any occasion over Sansa
and it's like she was implying that she
kind of wants Jon not to returns this
also could rule or I could see what's
really underneath people are actually
presenting to everyone else yeah and to
have that just reunited they just
reunited and now those are ready to
tension and conflict between the two of
them yeah it's getting it's making me
wonder where their relationship is
headed now yeah it starts good like we
wanted it starts to come together so
much and now are the stars going to
separate in some ways are going to be
some type of relationship conflicts
happening and that's what I'm wondering
about especially in La Aria even still
kind of young and he's just seeing
something again after so long she spent
a lot of time trying to you know leave
her old life behind enough she's like
re-embrace again but she is a different
person she's a bit stranger yeah now you
know especially like you watch that
scene with hot pie from last week where
she's acting all funny eating the pie
yeah yeah I mean I got it almost
foreboding sense from that scene I don't
think they're gonna like flat-out turn
on each other but I don't think this
conflict this conflict is going to reach
a head it's alright especially now that
she's got the she's
the note yeah you know in Littlefinger's
room what doesn't that no mean I thought
it was the old note that she was once
forced to write I think was the sense of
robbed or - Artie I remember Circe in an
earlier season had a write a note and I
think was when REO was missing so they
wanted a fine artist I think it was send
a note to her or it was to send a note
to robbed when they were going to war
with Rob I was limited in that note I
looked it up online
oh you did oh yeah yeah because there
are some naívi this is a sick show with
a lot of things or a lot of details
that's why they say like the old maester
like he kept records of literally
everything and that's one of those
things yeah yeah Littlefinger is up to
no good and perfect even notes of
everything
Gentry kendry yeah him returning yeah
first I was like this guy who was he
again remember I don't know I remembered
this Eber Melisandre got naked on top of
you
Lord oh yeah oh yeah bastard Senator
Robert Baratheon I love that scene I
loved loved that scene because there is
no beating around the bush whatsoever
here you want me to come with you yes
all right okay yeah them out like quick
and fast pace that was he's got a couple
moments like that yeah later on when he
meets John Anglin yeah don't don't
mention all this stuff and he's like
immediately what's up in the son of
Robert Baratheon I do I feel like it's e
scenes that show that he is the son of
Robert [ __ ] you know even though he
wasn't raised by him you can see that
it's in his blood a lot of this show
deals with what's in your bloodline and
you can see that this is in this guy's
bloodline that is how Robert Baratheon
would have been to Plus John God got a
bastard friend yeah they can do all sort
of bastard Club you like bastard rings
and stuff like that Tyrion Jaime meaning
each other again after a slaughter on
the battlefield what an intense moment
right there you know I like that in
spend a lot of time with Tyrion having
to explain why I killed their father you
know they both you know people they both
know and Jamie you know while he hates
him for that Jamie also you can see he
understands well I saw that too yeah I
was there he knows his brother was a
yeah thing about Jamie that's so
conflicting is like he no like he it
seems like Jamie knows his family really
really well but he's always caught
between them yeah and he's only like
yelling them you know he's got clarity
more and more authority without it doing
his job and stuff well he's second
King's Landing man yeah it is just like
awkward scenario after awkward
conversation that guy was thirsty and
out Tyrion I don't want him to die yeah
and I thought they were teasing that the
end of the last episode and the only
thing that kind of settled me for that
was just like the way that last scene
played out I wasn't really gonna be dead
but yeah like I I'm worried about what's
gonna happen to him now and going back
to Genji really quick when Gendry kills
those soldiers that was a cool scene to
show us beforehand you know I thought it
would Johnny singing he's not a soldier
he doesn't know how to use a sword he's
really good with a hammer
you know that scene shows you right
there shows you doesn't have to tell you
like oh this guy can kill some people no
problem yeah yeah he did not hesitate
whatsoever you know and having played a
few RPGs and stuff like that you want to
have a guy in your team was like a big
meal a heavy wet hand level a lot of
guys at once you know when Gilly when
she was reading that letter fifteen
thousand seven hundred eighty two shits
she was talking about how Rhaegar was
married in secret and that links back to
how Jon Snow snow as a child yeah and
which means Jon Snow is the rightful
heir to the Trump ah in arms like yay
when we were watching that scene I was
feeling like Gilly just a background
player now the background character
she's that thing that Sam's motivation
all right but that's scene is hinting at
that she's probably going to be able to
reveal some information maybe to Sam who
can pass it along to Jon typically like
do you really
you have inheritance here yeah yeah yeah
insane his job has no idea there is a no
idea it makes it that much better
I don't think John is gonna take up the
throne no I think that he will learn it
he will learn the truth of his bloodline
but I think at the end of the day he
will valid me to Cersei
answers yeah damn yes sir Selah
Daenerys I think I think he will bow to
Daenerys probably think that she's
probably the rightful heir to the throne
I mean the episode ends in a couple
really good high notes you know the last
team with the Brotherhood the Hound you
know oh yeah like at all coming together
jor-el wildlings it was such an
interesting clash of Alliance right
there and no battles this episode of
course the one time we decided to do a
reaction there's no gravy battles they
could all I bet there will be one but no
nega nega you know next week can have
some crazy action and I'm not going to
be in town to watch it the way they were
shooting that scene like there's a bring
up the gate it took me a second to be
like oh they're going beyond the wall
again like they're going how they have
to yes my walkers yeah it's going to
mean wonder like what the hell are they
gonna do man it's just a few of them
like I said they're just gonna hide in a
bush and pulling it out dressed up like
what is Littlefinger up to make sure
I've had some kind of wedge between the
sisters man and because I like what
they've been doing a little finger this
season because they've kind of been
making him seem like he's not that
powerful or not that important but
that's the way little finger plays his
gameplay that's how he plays he stays in
the shadows he seems like he doesn't
have that much power but he's he has
something up his sleeve and Arya is not
there but he's on Arya like I feel like
this season will probably end like the
season finale will probably have a scene
where Arya kills Littlefinger
I wonder if it would because yeah I mean
he was like it's headed in that
direction yeah and the scene the earlier
scene with Varys interior made me think
of that the whole conversation they have
about you know you got to make them
listen to you yeah because everybody has
such a distinct mission and everybody
even if they're working towards the
greater good if they're working on you
know if it's working to get Daenerys
into into power what not these stills
everybody has their own motivation still
and that is like you're just watching
these advisers trying to make the power
people listen yeah and that's their
whole goal that made me think of that
later cuz I'm like oh this is how he
does it yeah this is how he snakes his
way in you know and and makes her listen
even though it wasn't like an
action-packed episode I still really
enjoyed the hell out of it because the
plot lines are just so interesting and
the strength of the show is not the
action the strength of the shows as
characters yeah actually this is a treat
yeah and you get plenty of character
here that was fantastic and it covered a
lot of ground in this episode like a lot
of different things happen a lot
traveling too
like how long does it take to say little
robot slamming as far as you know a
non-battle heavy episode goes I mean I
was wrapped I was doing a still attempt
and and Cersei and Jaime oh yeah sir
seems right man seriously is pregnant
again that poor child
humming - that poor horse hi Phineas
what are they excited to be having a kid
hi I know I lost three for a reason you
guys aren't meant to have children you
guys are in the middle of a crazy-ass
war right now you can clearly see
certain cities getting more drunk with
power as time goes along Jamie it
shouldn't be excited you gotta be the
logical one I fear what that that would
mean if Jamie were to truly accept that
mantle because I feel like the only
logical outcome is for him to kill sir
yeah yeah like I feel like he knows man
deep deep deep down you know he knows he
know she a she has to go man I don't
know if he's gonna make it because of
that no man I feel like Jamie might go
anyway guys what'd you think of the
episode I'm going to be in Colorado over
the weekend so I'm not going to be able
to film a reaction or a review for the
episode when I'll be back Tuesday night
so maybe I'll Wednesday John and I could
shoot one together whatever they wanted
don't watch Game of Thrones one's gone
don't watch Game of Thrones that's been
so much time binging episodes to not
watch game next minute we'll watch
together the video will be up late our
horse I'm excited I'm gonna have to
avoid social media
yeah don't use any electricity starting
6:00 p.m. Eastern Time okay I will have
to avoid social media until I'm back in
California watching the episode this is
how my lifestyle benefits me expose a
video very much anymore yeah will
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell that John Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram we have a patreon
go check it out a lot of fun perks over
there
much love reject nation yeah